everyone in the MCU has been fighting
over the Infinity stones for years now
even if movie audiences didn't always
realize their but what exactly are these
glowy rocks and tell where all the
Infinity stones finally brought together
here's how a knows the mad Titan got all
six Infinity stones on his pretty purple
fingers pretty much everyone in the MCU
from pizza quill to cull obsidian has
tried to get their hands on an infinity
stone at one time or another but with
everybody searching for these magical
rocks we should probably ask where do
the Infinity stones come from well
Marvel revealed the stones backstory and
guardians of the galaxy when the ragtag
sci-fi heroes fizz an eccentric antiquer
called the collector played by Benicio
del Toro as the collector explains to
star-lord and his crew before the
creation of the universe there were six
singularities then after the Big Bang
exploded everything into existence the
remnants of these systems were forged
into concentrated ingots Infinity stone
as a result these gems are incredibly
powerful with each one controlling an
element of the universe power space
reality time a soul and the mind and
unless you're some sort of celestial
being
you can't touch those stones with your
bare hands not for very long anyway
that's why Infinity stones tend to show
up inside orbs scepters glowing blue
cubes or a shiny gold glove Thanos is
one of the few beings who's seen who's
actually touched an infinity stone with
his bare hands but even the mad Titan
isn't strong enough to wield all six
gems on his own so in order to carry out
his plans of decimation Thanos needed a
hand
a giant golden hand known as the
Infinity Gauntlet this clever allows
Santos to harness the power of all the
stones but where did this ferocious yet
fashionable weapon come from well in
Avengers infinity war Thanos pays a
visit to near Evelio around populated by
oversized dwarfs
these are the worldly beings use the
heart of a dying neutron star to forge
powerful weapons like Thor's hammer
Mjolnir when Thanos arrived he forced
the dwarves to make him the gauntlet and
once he got the glove he murdered
everyone in new devaglia
except for King III played by Peter
Dinklage of course it's not like each we
got away unscathed as Santos took the
dwarfs hands and hopes had never fought
a weapon as powerful as the gauntlets
and from there Thanos set out to round
up the stones all while
King incredibly sharp when Thanos first
arrives an Avengers Infinity Ward the
mad Titan already has the power stone
ready to go so what's the story behind
this purple gem well the power stone
does exactly what its name promises it
gives a user incredible power in fact a
long ago the power stone was used by a
celestial to wipe out entire
civilizations and while other ambitious
beings tried to harness its energy they
were disintegrated quickly after coming
into contact with the stone in other
words unless you're this guy
you don't want to mess with the power
stone eventually the power stone was
placed inside a metal lob and hidden
away in the desolate planet of Morag
when Thanos learned about its location
he sent Ronan the accuser and Cora the
pursuer to retrieve it eventually the
guardians of the galaxy handed the stone
over to the Nova Corps an intergalactic
police force and the planet Xander for
safekeeping but when there's a genocide
or warlord running around nothing is
safe for long in infinity war we learned
that Thanos in his army have devastated
Xander and after murdering everyone in
his path Thanos retrieved the Power
Stone making it the first gem added to
his gauntlets so when he finally shows
up with that purple gem he's ready to
smash hulks and kill gods technically
the first Infinity stone to appear in
the MCU the space stone could manipulate
space and that uses teleport across the
universe it was originally housed inside
a cube known as the tesseract long
before the Marvel movies begin a
tesseract belonged to Odin for some
reason that the Norse God thought it was
a good idea to bring this insanely
dangerous rock down to earth and his
human worshippers hid the stone inside
in Norwegian Church hoping it would
never fall into evil hands unfortunately
that's exactly what happens in Captain
America the First Avenger during World
War two the Red Skull rolls into town
and captures the tesseract hoping to
create powerful weapons using the cubes
energy fortunately for Humanity Steve
Rogers shows up to save the day in the
film's final battle one that takes place
in a Hydra war plain red skull foolishly
touches the tesseract which opens up a
portal and sends him hurtling into space
the cube then burns a hole through the
plane and falls into the Arctic Ocean
below of course the space stone wouldn't
stay submerged for very long after the
climactic events of Captain America the
First Avenger the tesseract was
discovered beneath the ocean waves by
millionaire inventor Howard Stark from
there the cube made its way to shield
where in the 1990s and undercover Kree
scientist named Marvell used the space
stone to create a Lightspeed engine she
hopes the engine could help a persecuted
alien race known as the scrolls escape
their tormentors her own people and find
a new home but a plan didn't exactly pan
out a tesseract was stored aboard an
invisible Space Station for years
afterward finally being recovered by
Carol Danvers and Nick Fury during the
events of Captain Marvel from there the
cube was back in shields hands
a little while at least in the
post-credits scene of Thor we see Nick
Fury and dr. Erik Selvig admiring the
tesseract and talking about its
unlimited power unfortunately they're
not the only ones in the room Loki the
god of mischief is hidden in the room
too and he's got his eye on the glowing
blue cube as part of a deal with Thanos
Loki agreed to retrieve the space stone
from shield and give it to the mad Titan
in exchange for an alien army to help
him invade Earth
Thanos went a step further and gave Loki
an additional infinity stone the mine
stone to help subjugate earth more on
that in a bear
needless to say neither Loki North a
knows accounted for the combined might
of the Avengers as a result he's cuffed
and carted off to an Asgardian prison
Thor also takes a space stone back to
Asgard where it's stored away in Odin's
treasure room but things take a sad turn
and thor ragnarok when a now freed Loki
gets a bad case of light fingers this
proves to be a fateful decision for Loki
as he Thor and the rest of us guard
abandons their destroyed homeland
they're attacked by Thanos warship soon
Loki is forced to hand over the
tesseract giving Thanos the power to
easily teleport across the cosmos and is
such a powerful scene that even Loki
gets a little choked up
one of the scariest stones and Thanos
has gone let's the reality stone is a
ruby red gem that can alter the fabric
of the universe itself if you want to
turn a wasted planet into a green
paradise you can if you want to turn
Drax the destroyer into building blocks
you can do that too a bad guys have been
trying to use the red stone for evil
purposes since ancient times in Thor the
dark world we learned that Dark Elves
wanted to plunge the universe into
eternal night and to do that they needed
the reality stone specifically a
liquefied version of the stone called
the ether fortunately way back in the
day King Borodin stared at the feet of
the elves and when the creek just came
back for round two Thor hammers things
out and captures a reality stone
canceling their dark plans however the
Asgardians were worried about housing
the reality stone next to the space
stone so they handed it over to the
collector for safekeeping on knowhere
sure the collector was a shady dude who
wanted the stones for his own purposes
but none of that mattered when Sano
showed up and burned nowhere to the
ground now with the reality stone in his
possession
Thanos can shape the world exactly as he
sees fit the most mysterious of the
Infinity stones the soul stone has only
appeared in one Marvel movie so far
Avengers infinity war after a little bit
of old-fashioned torture Thanos learns a
soul stone is hidden on the misty
planets of four Mia with his adopted
daughter forcibly in tow Thanos arrives
on for Mia to discover a ghosty Red
Skull guarding the gem he explains
there's only one way to get the soul
stone to sacrifice what you love the
most and for Thanos that means tossing
the moor off the side of a cliff after
trading her life for the stone he's one
Rock closer to completing his collection
so what does the soul stone do
well obviously manipulates souls or as
directors Anthony and Joe Russo puts it
the essence of who you are in the comics
it can trap spirits and a weird
dimension called the soul world and it's
possible that everyone fellows killed in
the decimation is locked in a cinematic
version of this little universe we also
saw the soul stone in action when Thanos
was battling Doctor Strange on Titan
when the sorceress splits up into like a
hundred strangers
Thanos used the stone to reveal the true
sorcerer and according to the Russo
brothers Fellowes used the soul stone to
speak to his dead daughter
meaning he's got ability to resurrect or
conjure the spiritual representation of
people who are dead so while its powers
are still a bit ambiguous
Stone is so freaky because it gives
summers power over death itself the time
stone gives users the power to
manipulate the past present and future
basically it's a time machine inside a
necklace known as the eye of agamotto in
dr. strange a surgeon turned source for
us to even stranger learns how to
manipulate time with the eye and uses it
to defeat the interdimensional demon
Tamamo strange then becomes a protector
of the stone so when Thanos his children
show up to run an errand for daddy it's
strange it's time to shine
eventually the good doctor and several
other heroes arrive on the desolate
world of Titan where they eventually
battle Thanos for control of the stone
and that's when things take a very
strange turn using the time stone
strange looks into the future and
perceives all possible outcomes for
their battle with Panos and there's only
one in 14 million outcomes were the
Avengers when believe it or not that
scenario require strange to hand over
the green gem to Thanos so when the mad
Titan is about to murder Tony Stark
strange Faulks it over with a cryptic
explanation as to why why did you do
[Music]
we're in the endgame
he is hoping strangers mystery plan
makes a little more sense when endgame
rolls around back in the first Avengers
film Loki shows up with a fancy scepter
that lets him control Minds a power
granted by the yellow mine stone lodged
inside us blade as we all know Loki is
defeated by the end of that film and the
scepter is kept by shield for further
study in the hopes that their scientists
can unlock its mind-controlling
mysteries unfortunately as we find out
in Captain America the Winter Soldier
the spy agency had been infiltrated by
Hydra agents and they use the sphere to
create super-powered beings to fight the
Avengers namely Quicksilver and Scarlet
Witch their incredible abilities come
courtesy of the gem however they're not
the only ones and future Avengers to owe
their powers to the mine stone in age of
Ultron of the evil robot was brought to
life by the mine stone and unfortunately
for Humanity Ultron is a big fan of
extinction events he's also really into
building himself stronger bodies two
houses artificial consciousness and his
ultimate creation as the super sleek
body made of vibranium when old Tron
unleashes the mind stone from the
scepter and slaps it on the new body's
forehead he hopes to give his future
self powers beyond belief fortunately
the Avengers ruin Ultron's makeover with
the help of Thor's lightning they bring
his new creation to life known as the
vision at this Avenger is a nearly
omnipotent being inextricably linked to
the mine stone so when Thanos shows up
an infinity war vision offers to
sacrifice himself if he destroys the
stone he'll die but it will also ruin
Thanos tennis idol plans eventually
visions girlfriend the Scarlet Witch his
force to pull the trigger since her
powers come courtesy of the mind stone
only she can destroy the gem lodged in
visions forehead but despite their noble
efforts the mad Titan has a time stone
by this point and simply rewinds time
and he joins her mind stone from vision
skull leaving the Android crumpled on
the ground so what happened to the
Infinity stones after the decimation
well that fateful snap definitely left
Thanos and his club looking a little
worse for wear on the Avengers infinity
war commentary director Joe Russo
explained the effect the decimation had
on the villain the power that it takes
to use all six stones is significant and
clearly damaged the gauntlet and damaged
Pharaoh's permanently still despite the
glove being badly burned at this
or seem to be intact and phallus uses a
space stone to portal out of Wakanda so
evidently the gems are still working and
they will most definitely play a part in
the upcoming battle in the promotional
materials for endgame is clear that
Thanos is still wearing that gauntlet
while off playing farmer and even though
the mad Titans arm has been burned to a
crisp there's no doubt the stones will
make things infinitely more difficult
for the Avengers when they face off with
a genocide or warlord for the final time
keeping track of the Infinity stones can
be confusing especially since there are
so many glowing blue objects in the MCU
on the mine stone which is yellow
appears in Loki's scepter it gives off a
blue hue the tesseract obviously is a
glowing blue cube on top of that there's
a casket of ancient winters yet another
blue cube that appears in 2011 store but
don't be confused Marvel fans the casket
of ancient winters has nothing to do
with the tesseract or the Infinity
Gauntlet so even though it's a glowing
blue cube the casket has nothing to do
with the space stone still it's a pretty
cool q speaking of confusing props back
in 2011 Marvel was still figuring out
where to take their franchise they
hadn't settled on the infinity war
storyline and they didn't even know that
US would be a major player and thought
Joss Whedon decided to toss him into the
Avengers so when it came time to release
Thor the folks at Marvel weren't
thinking about the long-term
ramifications of one little Easter Egg
drawing Thor's aborted coronation some
frost giants attempt to steal the casket
of ancient winters from Odin's treasure
room and during this scene eagle-eyed
fans will notice an Infinity Gauntlet
complete with all six stones on display
in Odin's vaults but how could that
o--'s be hunting for all the Infinity
stones if Odin already had the full set
obviously it's just meant to be a fun
easter egg
but once the franchise started down the
Infinity warpath Marvel had to figure
out what to do with their little gag
gone wrong eventually thor ragnarok
fixes this error in the best and most
hilarious way possible when hello the
goddess of death stormed into Odin's
treasure room
but that's not the only Infinity
Gauntlet confusion we've seen in the MCU
after the credits are done rolling an
age of Ultron Thanos storms onto the
scene and makes a declaration however in
this scene he already has his Infinity
Gauntlet which doesn't line up with the
MCU timeline let's dive in nerd alert
age of Ultron was released in 2015 and
we see that Thanos has his glove ready
to go
but when infinity war came out three
years later it seems like the mad Titan
had just recently forced the Eitri to
forge the gauntlet so what's going on
here well the writers of infinity war
have absolutely no clue speaking with
slash filmic Christopher Markus and
Stephen McFeely admit the age of Ultron
seen as and baffled in terms of the
timeline the Russo brothers however have
tried to wreak on the situation speaking
with comic-book comm the directors
explained the Infinity Gauntlet we see
an age of Ultron is the same one from an
infinity war said Joe Russo I think that
it would be connected to each ray I
think that clearly he is the one that
forced the gauntlet and Thanos had the
gauntlet at that point in time it's been
a while since any of the Asgardians have
interacted with each tree and his people
in other words each tree has been
hanging out alone in space of no hands
for years and that sucks for him now
sure the Russo's explanation might not
work out perfectly if you look too
closely at all the details but in a
franchise that's beautifully spanned
over 20 films with fun with explaining
away a continuity error or two check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about Avengers
and game are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]